hey everybody thank you for watching my
Eclipse Channel this clip is about Shane
gallup's flying private jets around with
Chris Rock Joe Rogan now candidly
private jets are not that good for the
environment but you know what is liquid
death water and they brought this to you
so stick around to the end to find out
how killer of a deal they're offering
you now let's get to it it's even doing
spots in the the clubs odd but you're
touring too yeah yeah on the weekends
yeah yeah okay so I just I did Boston
and then I drove all the way down to
Philly on Sunday
no I was at uh laugh Boston Thursday
Friday Saturday and then they were like
do you want to open for Chris Rock in
Philly and I was like definitely so I
drove [ __ ] it was like seven and a
half hours yesterday that sucked just to
show up and you came did Philly and then
this morning I drove up here um [ __ ]
yeah my buddy Eric Andre was uh doing
some shows with Chris Rock and he's said
that like
that it was so impressive Chris Rock
would have somebody record the show oh
yeah and then immediately after the show
that recording would be sent to like a
stenographer who would like type up a
script of the show yeah and then he'd be
pouring over the script of the show to
see where he could like eliminate words
yeah I mean it was it was crazy he had
yeah he had like bulletins of what he
was going to say I think he had it on
stage like so he could see his [ __ ]
because he went he did like an hour and
a half at least it's it's really [ __ ]
impressive and it was cool to watch like
it was just sitting backstage watching
Chris Rock I was like damn did you tell
that's as cool as it gets did you tell
them man I think that getting slapped
was the best thing yeah that's what I
said I said look I think it probably
helped honestly everybody told me not to
say this but yeah yeah but like don't
you think that like how how big was the
venue it was huge it was it was his
third night there yeah Auditorium yeah
but I didn't I didn't think it was going
to be as many black ladies
Chris Rock's crowd would be a lot of
honkies that's what I was anticipating
when I showed up to go on stage and I
was like oh I'm gonna bomb
they liked it yeah so how did uh the
invite get extended to you I don't know
it's just through my agents that's
Prince did he know that I mean it's
seven hour drive that's pretty well I
was yeah I was excited yeah so of course
yeah how long did you do uh like 15 yes
quick 15.
man yeah it was cool there's no way that
like that he saw your schedule and it's
like oh well no I think he was just uh
yeah he's seen me at the cellar a bunch
and was like he's funny see if he wants
to do it I was like yeah definitely
you're talking backstage yeah we went
out and got dinner it was it was sick it
was awesome yeah
yeah that's right and then the next
level is if you're gonna do more than
one night you're on his private jet with
them yeah I'll be sick I just took one
of those for the first time me too where
it was scary yeah I don't like it yeah
where'd you go I was with Rogan we went
to the UFC two nights ago yeah yeah
yeah I wanted every podcast I go on I'm
like yeah me and Nate are a good friend
he's like dude what are you talking
about dude I saw you on the broadcast
like I said yeah this is my fat face the
closest
Gladiators are fighting I'm sitting
there eating [ __ ] chicken fingers
okay that's that's epic man yeah so you
you love watching the fights yeah yeah
especially next to [ __ ] Rogan and
them are sitting right here you're right
there and you're just it's terrifying I
mean it's truly terrifying the only
thing that sucks about going to see the
UFC fights in person is that you can't
hear the commentary I know Rogan and DC
and Anna yeah dude they're so good right
but if you're sitting right next to
Rogan are you able to hear I can hear
the screams like if somebody gets hit
it's like oh but the whole crowd's
screaming too so right the you know what
I've done like is I'll be at the
Pay-Per-View event in the arena and I've
got my [ __ ] headphones and I'm
listening to the UFC fight pass but it's
like uh it's like an uh like a minute
and a half delay or something so I'm
hearing the commentary like I'm like a
minute and a half yeah yeah and I just
don't care because I love their
commentary so much yeah and they they'll
tell you what the [ __ ] going on
because I'm sitting there like you have
no idea I can't tell if somebody blocked
it or if somebody just got kicked in the
head well yeah it's like a submission
attempt oh that's time yeah yeah he's
got to lift the [ __ ] right arm up or
something yeah he's gonna do like it's
just so fascinating man I love it dude
yeah that shit's awesome the first one I
went to with him was in Gano versus
Cyril gone okay there's a heavyweight
champion Francis and Gano from like me
to you is the scariest dude oh yeah you
guys had him on the [ __ ] thing yeah
that's right
it was about what you would think it it
is like he's yeah it's not quite like
when you meet uh an NBA basketball
player and they're like so like you're
not prepared freaks dude like from what
you can watch basketball on TV until
you're blue in the face it nothing will
prepare you for me Shack or likes you
know like it's like wow it's not like
that when you meet in Connor but it's
more like what you would expect like
he's huge yeah he's terrifying yeah
and he's also the most soft-spoken
nicest guy like yeah that's even scarier
right it's like dude what's going on in
there yeah yeah it's kind of a [ __ ]
though yeah
[Laughter]
yeah and uh what's crazy too is that I
had no idea that they were gonna do like
so many different like super violent
things to Danger Aaron with the cup test
all I knew
because that was the first one of them
yeah so I'm on the set that day and
they're like oh dude Francis and Ghana
is coming to set today I'm like what
they're like he's gonna punch danger
Aaron and the balls with the cup I'm
like dude I start campaigning like I
want because I'm such a fan I'm like I'm
like let me get the nutshot from Francis
and ganu and they were just like nah
dude like like this one's going to
Danger yeah and how [ __ ] up was he it
was like thank God he didn't like it
didn't just look like he was holding
back like he went for it yeah it was
great yeah and I ended up after seeing
how many different [ __ ] things they
did to Danger Aaron's balls like I'm so
glad that I got shut down when I asked
for that yeah couldn't be more thrilled
that I was not a part of that [ __ ] you
did the one though the the t-ball one I
did the I did the t-ball yeah he had no
cup that was that was that was brutal so
go to
liquiddeath.com
Stevo for free shipping on all your
stuff and feel good about how you're
both saving the world by bringing death
to plastic and being a healthier person
by drinking more water
throw away the soda drink liquid death
yeah dude